[Musica]
alexa uccelli ed ex foggia beh quello
che ho appena fatto è un'azione che
probabilmente accade quotidianamente
nelle nostre case cioè l'interazione con
un assistente vocale lo smart speaker
cos'è lo sma speaker me è ormai
l'oggetto di tendenza se ne contano più
di 200 milioni oltre 200 milioni di
dispositivi in tutto il mondo e il trend
è in aumento
andremo verso molto velocemente verso il
mezzo miliardo entro l'anno prossimo
cosa serve la nostra evoluzione della
nostra pigrizia riusciamo eseguire
azioni stando comodamente seduti sulla
nostra poltrona usando semplicemente la
voce questi dispositivi interpretano la
nostra voce e riescono eseguire
determinati comandi come abbiamo fatto
notare stanno diventando tantissimi e
stanno andando sempre di più nelle
nostre case questo perché perché non è
soltanto lo smart speaker il giocattolo
in di interesse è cosa lo smart speaker
può andare a comandare fateci caso se
per caso vi è capitato di acquistare una
nuova abitazione con classe energetica a
più più e così via c'è sempre il
capitolato dalla domotica il capitolato
della domotica altro non è al giorno
d'oggi che serrande serrature lavatrici
anche televisori che hanno un proprio
computer quindi sono dispositivi smart è
in grado di ricevere determinati comandi
o tramite applicazione smartphone oppure
in grado di interagire appunto con il
nostro comando vocale
il lo smart spi che l'assistente
personale riesce a mandare comandi e far
eseguire determinate azioni a questi
elettrodomestici che ormai hanno anche
questi totalmente invaso le nostre case
il video che vi sto per far vedere è
probabilmente l'evoluzione che ci sarà
nel prossimo futuro
se faremo un uso eccessivo di questa
tecnologia
adesso che gli impianti meetings di
calendar meeting
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao
[Musica]
sivori de tema che costa questo è un
problema serio
questo perché se questi dispositivi
fossero stupidi ci potremo seriamente
trovare in queste condizioni cioè uscite
dal dentista non avere più la bocca che
funzionano cento per cento e avere nello
smart speaker che non capisce la nostra
richiesta perché né ci riconosce man e
proprio ha compreso quello che stiamo
dicendo
infatti questi speaker queste tecnologie
in realtà non sono delle semplici
scatolette con un microfono è uno
speaker per far sentire cup che ha
compreso la nostra richiesta
in realtà al loro interno
forse non tutti volevo sapete ma c'è una
vera e propria intelligenza artificiale
non soltanto all'interno dello smart
speaker ma anche in un mondo esterno
infatti questi smart speaker se sono se
non fossero collegati alla rete non sono
completamente inutili
se io l'ho attacco alla spina e non
faccio tutte le procedure l'alexa di
turno non in grado di comprendere ed
elaborare la mia richiesta
questo perché perché esiste tutto un
ecosistema dietro in chissà quale parte
del mondo tra l'altro in realtà sui
luoghi sono ben noti e dove li che
avviene la meraviglia dell'elaborazione
lo smart speaker che prendere la nostra
il nostro audio la nostra richiesta
lo spara verso in questo caso il cloud
di amazon
ed è proprio lì che c'è tutto
quell'ambaradan dell'intelligenza
artificiale che cerca di inter e di
comprendere la richiesta di elaborarla e
soprattutto di interagire
sostanzialmente con i dispositivi che ho
configurato in cui ho dato la
possibilità di poter associare e
parlarci soprattutto bene quel mondo lì
è un mondo un po non dico oscuro perché
un termine sbagliato per un mondo di cui
si sa veramente poco
è un mondo di cui sta veramente poco
anche perché poi in continua evoluzione
e se dovessi usare una metafora beh io
lo paragono un attimo al sottosopra
quanti di voi piace strangers things
immagino a molti di voi qualcuno
sta usando la mano infatti il sottosopra
è quel qualcosa nel caso della serie tv
che sappiamo che esiste ma di cui non
conosciamo assolutamente la natura cosa
avviene cosa potenzialmente potrebbe
avvenire e di quel sottosopra che vorrei
parlare cioè quel substrato di contesti
eventi che probabilmente nessuno ad oggi
vi ha mai parlato e mi ha detto che
esiste
beh per esempio recentemente sono
saltati fuori e delle problematiche
legate alla riservatezza delle nostre
informazioni
cosa intendo intendo che alcuni
ricercatori hanno scoperto che è
possibile eseguire gli attacchi di
phishing
avete presente quando ricevette la mail
che qualcuno si spaccia per qualcun
altro vi richiede password carta di
credito ecco lo stesso identico e
tipologia di attacco informatico è
possibile farla tramite assistente
personale
questo perché voi l'utente finale
ascolta quella voce e alexa che me lo
chiede noi ovviamente da belli
intelligentoni rispondiamo a quelle
richieste e gli forniamo magari
determinate informazioni come la nostra
cartella ed e quant'altro
come è possibile questo è possibile
perché esiste la possibilità di
sviluppare delle vere e proprie
applicazioni terze parti quindi stefano
fratepietro che sviluppa un applicazione
è possibile installare quindi l'utente
volutamente devi installare queste
applicazioni di terze parti
il problema che è si deve fidare
ciecamente di cosa fa con l'applicazione
è potenzialmente parlando se
l'applicazione malevola potrebbe fare
esfiltrazione dei dati cioè non
elaborare queste informazioni e flauti
amazon ma semplicemente man arles e da
tutt'altra parte
un'altra problematica come vi ho
accennato prima che questi smart speaker
gli assistenti personali comandano
comandano gli elettrodomestici di casa
nostra
la serratura come abbiamo visto il video
per aprire la porta sono in grado di
effettuare determinati comandi a
determinati dispositivi e questi le
seguono per esempio ho scoperto che a
casa mia
il mio televisore
accetta comandi senza porsi la domanda
delle chi è che mi sta facendo questa
che mi sta ordinando di seguire questa
determinata azione e nel caso in cui
quello nero in alto il mio televisore a
livello di rete e il nel caso del mio
televisore lui non si pone la domanda su
è veramente stefano fratepietro che mi
sta chiedendo di eseguire quella
determinata azione è la segue
provate a immaginare nel caso in cui il
vostro la svolta smart tv e adesso se ne
vendono tantissime a integrata alla
webcam e il microfono in quel caso
qualcuno un attaccante potrebbe chiedere
tramite il assistente personale di
azionare il microfono è la webcam di
quel televisore e ascoltarci e
riprenderci non pensate che questo sia
fantascienza
assolutamente no perché molto spesso gli
assistenti personali magari vi sarà
capitato anche a casa vostra casa mia
capita molto spesso soprattutto quando
sono i miei figli a fare le richieste ad
alexa non il loro smart speaker si
attiva senza che effettivamente abbiamo
detto la palla alexa e questo è
l'interesse su questa problematica ha
impattato anche un recentissimo caso di
qualche anno fa dove un giudice degli
stati uniti ha chiesto ad amazon
se per caso quello smart speaker quel
assistente personale ad esse oppure no
ascoltato un dialogo prima di un
omicidio
la speranza del giudice era proprio
quella di ma per qualche motivo
l'assistente personale si è attivato e
ha registrato quello che effettivamente
si sono detti prima magari
dell'accoltellamento della persona e
questo un caso molto interessante perché
ci introduce un'altra tematica che
probabilmente non tutti voi se ne siete
a conoscenza
tutte le nostre richieste vanno sparate
come vedete nel cloud di amazon è la ci
rimangono è potenzialmente possono
essere ascoltate da dipendenti di amazon
da analisti di amazon
tant'è che è bloomberg recentissimamente
ha pubblicato un articolo dove ha
dimostrato e hanno dichiarato anche
amazon che è sostanzialmente esistono
flotte di persone che ascoltano proprio
gli audio delle nostre richieste
ma attenzione non cadiamo nel
complottismo perché questa cosa avviene
perché siamo noi stessi utenti che
abbiamo autorizzato amazon nell'eseguire
questo tipo di attività pulite quando
beh prima dell'installazione del
dispositivo sostanzialmente quando voi
fate il primo avvio del dispositivo
autorizzate amazon a migliorare la
vostra esperienza di utilizzo è proprio
una spuntatina quella spuntatina l'istat
autorizza ndaw nell'ascoltare tutte le
registrazioni delle vostre conversazioni
ma confine diciamo benevolo quello del
migliorare l'esperienza di utilizzo ed
evitare scene come quella di quel
ragazzo che è rimasto fuori alla porta
perché l'assistente personale non
comprendeva la richiesta di open doors
registrazioni
sì avete capito bene volente o nolente
tutto quello che voi chiedete viene
registrato e rimane lì rimane lì il
bello che rimane anche a vostra
disposizione cioè non tutti gli utenti
di degli assistenti personali sono a
conoscenza che potete andare via ha
ascoltate le richieste che chiunque ha
fatto vostro smart speaker quello della
mie spalle altro non è che il mio
pannello di richieste
sin dal primis te al primo giorno di
installazione la retention è infinita
cioè se vengono conservate tutte le
richieste però tener presente che siete
totalmente liberi di andarle ad
ascoltare e ovviamente anche a
cancellarle questo perché ovviamente
l'utente ha la massima libertà di
governo e controllo di quello che accade
fatte tutte queste premesse
qual è il messaggio che vi voglio
lasciare beh gli assistenti personali
sono pericolosi no gli assistenti
personali potrebbero costituire un
pericolo per la nostra lepre
riservatezza dei nostri dati beh dipende
in questo caso dipende da come li usiamo
la metafora che spesso uso è quella del
benzinaio perché i benzinai esistono
beh molto semplice io ora ho una
macchina che ancora brucia gasolio
benzina vado al benzinaio riempio e vado
però se io vado da un benzinaio con una
bottiglia di vetro
la riempio di benzina e ci metto sopra
un panno o creato una bomba molto ma non
per questo motivo dobbiamo chiudere
tutti i benzinai d'italia per paura che
la gente iniziasse a fabbricare delle
bombe
il messaggio quindi è sempre il contesto
di consapevolezza cioè adottiamo le
queste tecnologie
facciamole anche nostre perché comunque
servono per migliorare la nostra vita
quotidiana
anche stando sbarcati sul proprio divano
con l'obiettivo però è l'impegno direi
di tutti noi di non fare la fine di
questo signore di questo fumetto alexa
sony qualcosa di genesi alex in sala
stai parlando con la scatolette del
tonno
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]